is something that you called on the
Biden Administration to do which is just
to Simply ignore the Court ruling that's
a pretty
stunning position if you think about it
when this case is resolved by the
Supreme Court
should the administration follow that
decision if that decision ends up
Banning this abortion drug courts rely
on the legitimacy of their rulings and
when they make a mockery of our system a
mockery of our democracy and a mockery
of our law then I believe that that the
executive branch and we know that the
executive branch has an enforcement
discretion especially in light of a
contradicting rule she is a living
walking breathing mockery of democracy
by her as a congressperson in one branch
of government calling on another branch
of government the executive branch to
ignore the decisions of the third branch
the judicial branch I think she's in a
violation of her oath of office